i'm here pulling us here polina actually
didn't know she was gonna make it today
woke up this morning we said hey we
gotta get we gotta go do the work i get
a haircut you did get a haircut it looks
beautiful you look great what's our
first topic uh oh actually hold on
timeout before we get to the first topic
ftx is sponsoring this segment of lunch
money
i read yesterday matt levine from
bloomberg he put together an entire
write-up about ftx and their move to try
to get a certain type of
derivative uh i'm gonna call execution
technology
ftx is constantly innovating the whole
idea of margin in the legacy world
according to my learning from matt
levine is that
if i have margin and i get margin called
and i'm a big institution or a big
family office the banks will call up and
be like hey uh we're not actually going
to call the margin or we're not going to
liquidate you because we know you we
like you uh we think that we should
extend you some extra time etc it's all
like personal relationship stuff ftx is
proposing to actually offer margin to
customers and say it's not about
personal relationships it's all should
be algorithmic everyone should be
treated the same and so if you put up
collateral and you take margin and
there's a margin call you don't cure the
margin call then you should get
liquidated and there's no playing
favorites there's no oh i know this
person i know that person oh there's how
much i might trade with this person how
much money we might make just make it
all algorithmic if you haven't yet go
read matt levine's piece on it it's
fantastic but the key takeaway is ftx
continues to innovate part of the
innovation is they're also bringing
stocks
to the same application where you can go
by bitcoin cryptocurrencies the stocks
as we've talked about there's no trading
fees and there's no payment for order
flow no trading fees no payment for
order flow they constantly keep saying
how do we innovate in infrastructure and
in the market to provide the best value
to our customers go download the app ftx
you can click on the link in the
description and you'll be ready to rock
and roll now
what up polina oh hey let's go jamie
diamond
all right all right all right
so jamie dimon has some thoughts i agree
with him about what you don't even know
what my thought or his what he said
he said he warned people to brace for an
economic hurricane pointing to the fed
and russia's invasion of ukraine
actually i know you have thoughts
because i heard you talk about it
earlier
my general thought is that jamie dimon
one is obviously incredibly intelligent
he runs one of the largest banks in the
world he's got massive amount of
information at his fingertips uh and
what he said around like brace yourself
the reason why i agree with him is
because he clearly says like nobody
knows how bad this could get yeah and
nobody knows how long it could go but
it's obvious that the federal reserve is
conducting quantitative tightening when
they do that there's a direct inverse
relationship meaning that if they
tighten stock and other asset prices go
down they claim that they're going to
continue to tighten and so if they do
that asset prices will likely continue
to go down and so in that scenario you
should be prepared just go ahead and
make sure you've got a strong balance
sheet and that you can last for a long
time i think that's great advice and you
should do that even if there's no
uh
correct recession on the horizon good
times bad times you should always make
sure that you get strong balance sheet
right build a good business have
personal
stability uh by having that strong
balance sheet now his thought process is
it's not just the fed though there's
also russia and ukraine he doesn't think
that europe is doing a great job uh and
the rest of the world are preparing for
high oil prices like there's all this
complexity in the global macro
environment and his main message was i
used to say there's a storm on the
horizon now i think there's an economic
hurricane coming towards us and the
problem with hurricanes is you don't
know if it's going to be a minor one or
super storm sandy and so you should be
prepared for the worst and if it doesn't
end up being that bad then you're fine
and so i think that that's actually like
a pretty fair way to look at the world
and frankly having him come out and say
this there's plenty of people like oh
they're fear-mongering whatever he's
like look we're gonna be super
conservative with our own balance sheet
too so don't even listen to what they're
saying just watch what they're doing so
i don't even think that they're
initially making money by doing any sort
of fear-mongering right i think that
he's just saying look this is what we're
gonna do and this is why we're gonna do
it you guys make your own decisions
you're big boys and girls
fair
do you agree with them yeah oh no but i
mean it's a very like i could have said
that
obviously it's either going to be a
small recession or a big recession
is it going to be a recession
yeah they're claiming that there's going
to be economic growth in q2 no no
ooh is that a economic prediction yes
wow okay well just given what's going on
in the rest of the world i don't think
the u.s is immune to any of it in fact i
think the u.s caused it okay
hey hey hey
y'all who didn't know bellino's a sad
dude
and i'm sleep deprived all right let's
go cheryl sandberg cheryl sandberg is
stepping down from her role as co at
meta the company formerly known as
facebook i saw a bunch of people joking
on twitter that it's only a matter of
time before she joins a venture capital
firm venture capital firm i also saw
somebody say that elon must post her to
twitter
that could be interesting
uh what do you think about this do you
like this idea of what twitter no of her
stepping down like well to be totally
honest i literally forgot that cheryl
was still at facebook i thought she had
moved on a long time ago she's been
there for 14 years i know but what has
she done can i can i uh say one thing
one when i worked at facebook i had the
opportunity to uh to work with her very
briefly
uh and you know met her saw her operate
etc um
and i was very impressed with her
ability to just drive yeah productivity
and so as a chief operating officer
that's what you would expect what i do
think is interesting is uh
facebook being an ad space business
being very kind of data driven a lot of
the things that facebook was famous for
and still is uh they're starting to
change something now it's like meta now
it's like oh we're going to the
metaverse like it's not so much the same
business and so i do wonder like how
much does she sitting there saying like
is my skill set actually good to apply
here i don't know also 14 years like
you've been somewhere for a decade and a
half like you just may want to do other
things i forgot you were still there
that's a bar that that's true and then
the last thing i would say is uh she's
dealt with a lot of personal um
tragedies well her husband uh
unfortunately passed away on a freak
accident um
and uh you know it's just i i don't
think that like this is like some crazy
crazy thing uh and i don't necessarily
know if i believe in any of the
conspiracy theories except
if she did go run twitter that would be
wild that would be so that'd be wild all
right next speaking of elon musk has
trashed remote work
he said tesla employees should pretend
to work somewhere else if they're not
willing to return to their offices
what do you think
[Music]
i mean what anyone who wishes to do
remote work must be in the office for a
minimum and i mean minimum of 40 hours
per week or depart tesla this is less
than we ask of factory workers
i mean do you agree with him
so in terms of tesla
maybe
in terms of twitter or anything else no
but also isn't he kind of running remote
companies
what he's got like spacex tesla
uh all the other open all the other
companies here's my read what
one you can't build a rocket
virtually that's what i was gonna say
you can't build a car virtually right
that's first but even more importantly
if you guys sit down and you really
think to yourself really really think to
yourself are you more productive working
at home or working in the office you are
liar and you're lying to yourself if you
think that you're more productive at
home than you are in the office because
you may say to yourself i enjoy the work
more i think that i end up actually
working quote unquote more hours because
there's not as much of a difference
between home and work or whatever
but
my guess is that as a unit when you
bring all these people together there's
drastically more productivity i've seen
multiple people talking about it saying
hey when we were out of office we
brought them back in the office bam all
our metrics go up and so now you're
starting to see more and more uh
investors talk about this entrepreneurs
etc get your ass back in the office
now the one thing that i will say is
it depends on the mission
if you're simply going to a place to
optimize some ads and get some clicks
like bro get out just get out of there
get out of there go work on something
that's fulfilling that actually you feel
excited to go to work because the
companies that are working on the hard
problems those types of things there's
people who wake up can't wait to get
into the office and actually get to work
because they feel like there's meaning
behind the work and so what i think
you're going to start to see is you're
going to see this bifurcation of the
people working on the hard problems
they're going to keep getting people in
the office they're going to keep having
productivity and it all is uh related to
not only in person but also the mission
the way that the company operates et
cetera the second thing is that the
companies who aren't working on hard
problems the companies that are just
bullshitting uh and trying to drive ad
revenue by clicks and et cetera people
are like oh bro it doesn't matter i got
my computer i worked four hours anyways
whether i do it in the office or at home
who cares like tesla's social media
manager probably doesn't need to i
worked at facebook
listen
i i tell people all the time
me and one of my friends who will go
unnamed we should put a meeting on our
calendar and for an hour every afternoon
we go to the gym
like by the way we got our work done
it's just like there's only so much work
to do when you work at a company with 12
000 employees by time i left somebody in
the comments i think this was meant
maliciously but i think it's funny they
said you haven't had a job since you
were in the military and facebook
doesn't count
i mean okay
sure
we were only one of the most viable
companies in the world
no he works more than anybody i know no
that's not true um all right but uh that
was a malicious comment
that was you're working too much uh but
the other thing i'll say is i love
reading the communications uh like this
like that was supposed to be a private
email who knows who leaked it uh elon
musk's savage
there's no fluff there's no anything hey
get your ass in the office if you're not
in the office go work somewhere else and
guess what a plus players like that's
where i want to work there you go
ready it's true speaking of elon musk
his ex amber heard
what a transition at a trial with her
other ex what a transition
johnny depp won his defamation case
against her and he a jury has awarded
him 15 million dollars can you tell us
what the defamation
situation somebody in the comments i saw
said why the hell is johnny depp on the
topic list it's not important in my
opinion it's i put it on the list not
because of the sensational significance
but because it's somebody who majored in
journalism this will be in the history
books for the
what was the situation though what did
she say or did he say he's a sexual
predator etc and he's saying that oh she
came out after they broke up and said
all this and then he was like okay
he said that was defamation defamation
cases are really really hard to win
because you have to prove actual malice
was involved i'm pretty sure if you say
that then there's malice well and the
jury agrees with me well and also it's
even harder if you're a public figure
because like we're allowed to say
whatever we want about jamie dimon
whatever but like because they're a
public figure they're
it raises or whatever raises the bar
defamation is just really hard and the
the fact that he won this is insane hey
you know why right why don't don't [ __ ]
with jack sparrow
[Laughter]
that's why
100
i don't care what anyone says when you
have a jury trial and you have somebody
who is like oh the pirates of the
caribbean whatever you can try to filter
out all you want a weird dude but you
can try to fill out all you want for
bias etc like you just have two people
there and
look at the memes on the internet the
sentiment was a hundred percent for
johnny depp in culture for literally
weeks you think the jury wasn't affected
by that
wow humans are humans i don't care what
anybody says that's the bad part of
human driven jury trials okay i don't
think that anyone can be 100
non-biased in a jury trial
if they know somebody who is in the
trial do we need a robot driven jury
trials no i don't think i don't think
that there's a better solution i'm just
saying that i also don't think that it
is what people claim it is like
everyone's unbiased it's the same thing
like journal journals like oh i'm
unbiased no you're not no
it's impossible for you to be unbiased
you're a human there's always bias but
that's why the lawyers go through their
little veto thing before yeah i
got i got the game i understand so she's
also getting 2 million in
com compens she's compensatory damages
yeah because apparently he kind of like
defamed her in some way i don't know
it's it's a whole thing i just like i
just like that he stunted on her at the
end i read on the internet yesterday i
saw a tweet they said this dude's been
in court the whole time and then the day
they read the verdict he was in a pub in
the uk
yeah he's wild there there's a really
good problem
on him i think in gq or esquire but
he's a he he's a weird guy but that
doesn't mean just because you're weird
that you're a sexual predator like
i think it was i think it was crazy okay
i also i also think there's a lot of men
right now
you know you guys ever seen the meme on
the internet city boys city boys rise up
city boys rise up
trust me you don't want to know
city boys rise up is because
all of a sudden a lot of men sitting
there saying hey wait a minute my ex
been saying all kinds of wild ass [ __ ]
about me then you you probably won't win
a defamation trial they may not do it
but i'm telling you there's a lot of men
i i know some of them are sitting there
being like
just just
just
you telling me i can get 15 million
dollars
no you can't that's what i'm here to
tell you you cannot lose text message my
friend sent me that my ex-wife said all
right
so
the education department said it would
wipe out the debt of 560 000 borrowers
who had an old
wait but this actually makes sense who
has
in the for-profit college chain called
cor
colleges uh which collapsed in 2015. i
think that's fine because they paid for
some sort of like fraud no you know what
this is this is a way to cancel student
debt without getting the blow back of
cancelling students the largest student
loan forgiveness action ever this is
dumb okay why is it dumb
it's a market but they they but but the
college engaged in wholesale financial
exploitation of students misleading them
into taking more and more debt to pay
for promises they would never keep i'm
okay with this
you got led into a scam
and you got scammed so why should
somebody else pay because you're dumb
enough to get scammed
no you're not yes if you forgive student
debt somebody else somewhere is paying
for the debt
the debt doesn't it's not like uh is the
debts written on a chalkboard and they
just go over and they erase the debt no
what happens is they say okay there's
5.8 billion dollars of debt meaning one
person owes 5.8 billion a combination of
individuals own 5.8 billion dollars to
somebody else whether that's the
government well that means i'm paying
for the loan forgiveness that means
you're paying that means everyone
watching is paying for it or if it's a
private company if it's a a non-profit
somebody somewhere has to pay
when the debt gets forgiven there is
ramifications to it and so this whole
idea of like oh we just wiped the debt
away and it just disappears and then we
all hold hands and sing kumbaya around
the fireplace like that's not what
happens
and so the way that they're gonna start
to do this now i see the playbook like
i got it like a little jack sparrow
i know exactly what they're gonna do now
they're gonna start looking for more
situations like this and they're gonna
start trying to uh relieve student debt
in situations
less controversial yeah
still don't get fooled don't get fooled
it's still student loan forgiveness
which means that they're intervening in
the market when you intervene in the
market it means that you throw off the
free market dynamics when you do that
you actually cause more problems which
news flash there's 1.5 trillion dollars
of student debt why because the
government literally guaranteed that
they were gonna pay it if you were a
college and you knew the government was
going to pay your bills what would i do
i'd jack the [ __ ] up out of the prices
that's true and when i do it the line
gets longer and the government will
still pay
monopoly it's asked money time fred l
asks which will happen first johnny depp
is broke again oh yeah he was or the
government for gives another student
load loan debt program
johnny depp was broke it's not depth
it's not johnny depp
his name however i want and nobody can
pronounce my last name so i have the
right to pronounce anybody else's last
name ronnie
okay johnny depp johnny d whatever
johnny depp was in johnny d sounds like
he should be on uh uh was it jersey
shore
uh he was in a relationship launching a
control spot um yeah he he was they
filed for bankruptcy hold on hold on did
he
i think he was just in really bad he was
he said he was broke johnny d was drunk
in a uk pub yesterday when he got uh 15
million dollars from his ex let me see
what his wife or girlfriend who was
talking [ __ ] to him hold on hold on
all right well we don't know but he was
in a real one time he said i am broke i
don't know all right so he was in a
baptist position uh i definitely think
that the student loan forgiveness yeah
what do you think well but johnny depp
doesn't have oh depth i know i'm saying
that no
i don't i don't think that he's going to
go broke again that's good you're just
saying that because you don't want to
get sued for defamation no i'm just
saying that i think that people who have
gone broke
people who have gone broke in the past
learn from their mistakes usually
because that is such a that's such like
a slap in the face like dude you were
real rich and then you were not very
rich and now you get money again
we'll see
unless he's a degenerate gambler then he
might blow tomorrow so this is not on
the topic list but i figured i would
have a little riddle
um so our flight yesterday was 12 hours
from istanbul to miami i was so long
what do you think is the longest
flight currently on the planet
which airline where and
how long 18 hours u.s to asia where in
asia
uh maybe japan
it's jfk to singapore
and it is 18 hours and 50 minutes
but 15 minutes almost 19 hours
i mean there's 24 hours that i could
have chose actually i could have showed
more than 24 hours and i got 18 as 18.50
i mean if you just drop that's how long
the minutes and you say how many hours
wait have you been on this fight because
you've gone from jfk to singapore i
wasn't going to say that but no but you
haven't been on this plane
both the flight from new york to japan
and new york to singapore both are like
very long 18 16 20 whatever that's crazy
all right love you thank you bye see you
that was a bad
thank you wait do one more time
[Laughter]
hey you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time